in this video you're going to see the
future not everyone is trying to win a
popularity contest case in point this
guy I don't think that popularity is
something he's interested in he's
interested in effectiveness his airtime
so to speak is only a tool to achieve
what his greatest aspiration is which is
to have a positive impact in the world
you should look at you know what was
your goal how are you trying to uplift
nutrition and survival and literacy he
is influential a because of his vast
fortune the way he made it by creating a
new segment of the computer market but
also that he sits and chosen to deploy
that the money he's made to try to
completely alter the landscape of world
health this year his net worth reached
as high as a hundred twenty billion
dollars these two have donated more
money to charitable causes than anyone
ever
he's a multi-dimensional individual he
has great depths in so many different
areas I guess you a polymath William
Henry Gates the third was born in
Seattle Washington in 1955 just how
difficult he was how much trouble he
gave his mother just you know yelling
screaming tantrums things like that at
the ripe age of 13 the problem child
wrote his first software program a
tic-tac-toe game on the teletype model
33 ASR teleprinter eight years later he
dropped out of Harvard to start a
computer software company with his best
friend Paul Allen called Microsoft in
co-founding Microsoft what Bill Gates
and Paul Allen did was essentially
create the personal computer software
market that's since then been worth
hundreds of billions of dollars this is
Jeff Raikes
he's known bill for quite some time now
I was at Microsoft from 1981 to 2008 and
Bill was completely committed to the
vision that we could help put a computer
on every desk and in every home running
great software and that's the impact
that he wanted to have and he was
completely focused in on that now such
determination does require a strong
personality and it's safe to say that
his subordinates could probably relate
to his parents at that point he was very
tough manager people were had these sort
of terrifying bill gates reviews of
their products and features and if he
didn't like what you said he would you
know he was known for responding with
the words well that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard but the good news
is you won't hold the record for long
Seattle's Bill Gates four point two
billion dollars is the second richest
person in the country what is this it's
Microsoft Excel now hold still I'm about
to perform a miracle my spreadsheet
doesn't do this
Microsoft became such a juggernaut that
the following decade they were sued for
being a monopoly if you look at that
point in the year 2000 Microsoft is in
serious antitrust trouble and the view
of Bill at that time was terrible people
viewed him as a sharp elbowed monopolist
essentially not that he cared about what
the world thought of him but it was
around this time that Bill decided to
start listening to his parents I do
remember in the early days of Microsoft
his mother pressing young bill to get
involved with the United Way and
philanthropy and Bill's response was you
know mom I'm you know I'm trying to
build this company i I don't really have
time for that
and I think over time what he learned is
in the same way that he could leverages
intellectual energy on behalf of
Microsoft he could do it on behalf of
philanthropy while in the midst of this
antitrust suit bill and his wife Melinda
donated 16 billion dollars with the
stock to charity in 1999 the following
year he poured 5 point 1 billion dollars
in cash to create the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation at this point I think
people many people much more closely
associate him with programs that have
saved lives and you know increased
immunizations in the developing world
that's much more the popular view of
Bill at this point that sort of
philanthropist and not a monopolist
so you can avoid lots of diseases if
you've been properly vaccinated today
the foundation is the world's largest
charity
it's fingerprint is on almost every
global health initiative of the last 20
years
and it spent over 40 billion dollars on
global development and public health
programs yes they deploy financial
resources but they also use their voice
the networks of influence and support
that they have so in many ways it
represents one of the key concepts that
we learned on software it's about
leverage what Bill wants what Melinda
watts with the foundation is to be able
to make those financial investments and
leverage them to have the greatest
possible impact by using this approach
to philanthropy the foundation provided
seed money to the Global Fund to fight
AIDS tuberculosis and malaria their
implementation of immunizations in the
developing world has contributed to a
dramatic drop in the overall child
mortality rate since 1990 bill also made
it his personal mission to eradicate
polio from the planet something he has
come very close to achieving then of
course there's Bill's noblest pursuit of
all I want to talk to you today about
toilets many people would say well why
get involved in
in toilets and how does that matter but
that you know actually kind of diving
into that explains a bit about how bill
thinks about things if you want to
reduce the disease burden you're gonna
have to improve sanitation if you're
gonna improve sanitation you're gonna
have to invent a new way to go about it
one that doesn't require all of the
water that we use today so it's a great
example of how he thinks in terms of the
broader system and looks for
technological innovations that can
really make a difference this push to
improve sanitation worldwide has led to
the invention of the omniprocessor a
low-cost human waste treatment plant
with a beta version currently in use in
Dakar Senegal I am very impressed with
this solution or seen here and it
generates electricity it generates clean
water in the area of climate change
Gates has embraced the often unpopular
solution of nuclear energy as an
alternative to fossil fuels the energy
has to come from somewhere you're giving
up all coal all natural gas all oil that
is a good example both in the fact that
he isn't concerned about public opinion
or popularity but but grounded in what
he believes to be the data and the fact
a gates company called Terra Power was
very close to building the world's first
nuclear reactor fueled by actual nuclear
waste in China but progress was stopped
in its tracks
when Trump launched a trade war against
China and 2018 no sooner was this vision
put on hold and it gates have a more
urgent calling this is going to be
era-defining and no one was in a better
place to say I told you so the most
urgent invention in the world right now
is a vaccine that prevents you from
getting Koba 19 the fact that he has
such depth across so many areas makes
him unique and being able to take on the
current pandemic he is now spent 20
years learning about funding programs
talking to leading researchers on things
like viruses things like vaccines some
of the programs in the Seattle area
including
a flu study that caught some of the
first phobic cases here are things that
have been funded out of the foundations
so far Gates is chipped in a total of
300 million dollars in Counting in the
fight against coronavirus they're
focused on detection isolation and
treatment of the virus and finding a
vaccine this chapter and Bill's life has
yet to be written and could have the
highest stakes he's had to face yet his
intellectual intensity sometimes carries
over to big expectations but at the end
of the day the person he's toughest on
is himself if he doesn't figure out
something that he thinks he should have
figured out he'll be disappointed in
himself it drives him it motivates him
it gives him a sense of urgency to
really make a difference and I think
that's one of his greatest attributes
[Music]
you